hello my name is mathias from data and
in this video
you would like to show how you can easily
evaluate your own data for people killed online delta is a
web-based statistics software which runs
directly here in your browser window
because it is a web application
it does not need it  to be downloaded
or installed
you can start calculating mounted deeds right in the browser if
you want to use your own
data first had to
click on table during
then there are three different
ways to insert your data in the tab
the first variant is just what you
you directly in the wave 1 tips e.g. age
12 years 15 years twelve years with
a variable name in the first line
and then the values ​​that are of
course a bit time-
consuming if you have a lot of data
so it can also just be your data
from one  excel files o'brien copy
so just copy di  e data
click on table whose accounts the acts in
if you have the premium version you can
also click on the board and
just move the next free track and
drop here so data
automatically recognizes which scales level your
variants have in for example the
income  only has numbers as values
therefore app automatically assigns okay it is
a metric variant comes in which was
you still have letters in front of you assigns
offender type the variant automatically has a number as a
nominal variable to of
course you can change that is a level
also
handle the simple refugees  task
view and now you can see all the
variables listed here change the name
or the climate
for example you coded the variable
gender with 1 and 2 you
copy this world into it thinks auto
updater first of all
it is an electric version they
are of course not
correct there we
would like to have it dealer so we just click  ch
on variable view when assigning
gender if we now simply
nominal and now we can also
determine the davis values,
for example for a
registered letter GW Rheine 2 male and if we now
look at the data again
we see the gender is b&m
coded and data has now assigned it correctly as a
nominal variable
you can make further settings under
settings here you can select what is considered to be
missing values ​​what is
to be achieved this time come
or point how many
decimal places you want or
how the  data reacted are the ones
discovered copied by default the
field is left empty
if you want to add a missing value, make
sure that the
many granted is added first
and then the data is inserted
story is the other way around we
inserted the act first and
then the  missing values ​​defined
recognizes the money  not right and
now we can start with the data analysis let's
click on
example that we have an example dataset
in the first step one of the
main calculation categories must be
selected i want to do descriptive
statistics i want a test
square test or a hannover
calculate a correlation analysis or
a regression analysis
i have selected that i can then
click on the variables below that i want to
analyze e.g. i click on the
tab perpetrator square test under nova
and velemir diamanti metric variable
income from
a simple perpetrator is automatically
calculated for me i select  two
variables from the independent
perpetrator is calculated for me above I can then also
select whether it is an independent
sample or my dependent
sample is it
a dependent sample is the
dependent thetis project and
can also select whether it is u  m is
a parametric test or
milk parametric test
moreover if now, for example, three variables
are automatically persuaded analysis
calculated the same applies if I select the
metric watts of a media player
and then select a variable
such as bad then
an independent perpetrator is automatically
calculated for me  this nominal variable
more than two characteristics e.g. place i automatically get
a choice analysis and
diet matching results then
a delta temple also
appears underneath it. data analysis with dating can be so easy if
you want more detailed information about
the different methods just click
on tutorial and you will find
the different ones here  methods that
can calculate with it and always finds the
theory and an example I hope
you liked the video if you have
any questions or suggestions
just leave a comment
thank you